hey welcome to new video number 68 so
every eight video we're gonna talk about
our current problems or challenges
actually do this wrong all the time it's
not every eight video but every 10th
video but then the eighth of it so 8 18
28 38 I didn't know how you say this but
anyway this is one of those videos so
let's talk about our challenges
so before looking into our new
challenges let's have a look at the
previous ones uh one was it's hot
really hot
very difficult to work and to do
anything but can I fix that one
we got some clouds
so now it's actually super nice good
temperature so uh challenge finished and
another big ongoing challenge we had
here for the whole year really is
integrating video making so you might
have actually seen this in these other
challenges videos but this has been a
recurring topic because it's quite hard
to integrate video making here and we
had Felix here the first half year but
he had to stop because it was a bit
intense for him to be here in this raw
setting but also hard to capture all the
different projects that are going on but
now actually for the first time in the
whole season it feels like it's kind of
under control which is really nice and I
think it's because we changed two tanks
so let me show you so first we change
the system on how we film so instead of
having one video maker going around to
film everyone we decided that people
film themselves so they go out there
with a camera tripod time lapse camera
and just capture the process they do we
give them a bit of instructions like how
it works but they are quite autonomous
which helps that the video maker doesn't
have to run all over the place and they
can just film it in a bit more depth and
detail which I think also improves the
quality of it so we ordered a bunch of
cameras all the same and all the same
time lapse cameras same microphone so we
really have a set that people can take
and film so that has been quite a change
which I think you guys have also seen in
the videos that the processes that
everything is a bit more documented as a
process and second we have a new video
maker he's already been around for a few
weeks but I realized we actually never
introduced him so this might be a good
moment hi this is Javier the new video
maker I'm from Madrid 36 years old and
I've been working as a freelancer for
about 15 years just finished my master's
degree in international cooperation and
I was looking forward to connecting it
with my job as a video maker feels like
being here at Camp serves this purpose
besides I have a big passion for music
food and jokes
planning to join season 3 stay tuned
it's been really nice to have him around
and I think he actually likes the rough
setting here and to work with
minimalistic tools and really find the
challenge in there so it's a good
combination we're actually looking into
season three and he's up for staying as
well which is really nice we still have
to go do some practical stuff but uh
this makes me kind of excited to see the
videos in season three if we have a new
video system and a video maker in a more
stable way to capture I think we can do
much more new and other things and grow
a bit the video team itself so should be
good for the season 3 videos
anyway so the previous challenges are
kind of okay it feels like but we have a
few new ones coming up let me show you
all right first challenge is flies uh
yeah there are a lot of flies around
here at this part of the year I think we
actually had it in previous challenges
as well but it feels like it's gotten
more intense maybe with more people but
they're just flies everywhere when
you're working when you're eating it's
like a drone flying next to your head
all the time
and I don't know actually how to go
around this if you need to plant other
things that avoid the Flies maybe it's
in general you're more intense because
it's a very young Forest that is growing
and not very stable yet
I don't know but if I think about this
that is for the rest of our lives
sometimes
but and it's not just me yeah some other
people have it as well
so uh
we are super sweaty and the Flies
I hate them
there are lots of flies in your cup yeah
not only my company everywhere
foreign
so I'm not sure what to do with this one
if you have some tips or tricks let us
know because all of us would be very
thankful
our Second Challenge is hot water so
here's our water setup and we get hot
water from electric boiler which is
inside solar panels on the roof that
heated up but recently we also installed
a gas heater which is right there for
the movements that we don't have enough
electricity
and this kind of works I would say we
always have hot water available enough
water enough heat but the downside is it
just is running on gas which we don't
like and realistically now we kind of
use it a lot because we are scaled up so
with more people and days like this when
there isn't enough sun it's impossible
to just get it from our solar which
feels kind of bad because we're using
this fossil fuel we have to drag these
gas bottles in and out far from ideal
for now it's okay because we're sort of
in this temporary setup here in base
camp but for the long term we would like
to have a different so we're now also
looking into our next big piece of
infrastructure which is going to be the
community center we're designing that
and seeing what it needs but uh yeah
taking hot water is kind of a big one to
take in account because by far most of
our energy goes there like the
electricity we use for charging your
laptop your phone the lights power tools
is nothing compared to heating up hot
water so yeah we really need to make
sure we integrate that one properly if
you have some suggestions or IDs let us
know
and until that time we're just
challenged by dragging gas in and out
very boring
and here we have our third challenge is
this a beautiful purple caddy so this
caddy has been challenging us quite a
bit a few practical things you just
can't move this chair so it's stuck I'm
always with my knees against the
dashboard the speed thing doesn't work
so you have no idea how fast you're
driving
there's a hole here with buttons missing
I don't know why and the back door often
gets stuck so then you I don't know
cannot open it
but those are kind of the Practical
things which is kind of okay we accepted
Place rough cars rough no problem
but recently it started having more and
more like engine problems
and we already thought it died twice but
it didn't and then we had a quick fix
and then it drives again and then you
fix it again but every time you invest a
bit of money in this car and effort but
then you really feel it's about to break
down so we've been looking for a new car
and we wanted to get a pickup actually
which is a bit more suited to our
terrain maybe even a 4x4 but those
things are surprisingly difficult to
find many people have them around here
but very hard to find second hand and
besides a car to drive we kind of also
need a tractor to really do some big
Landscaping work here on the land so we
need to upgrade our vehicles
um but yeah the downside of that is also
that
that just States money
which brings me to the fourth challenge
which is money
[Applause]
hey Challenge number four money let's
get into some numbers
so season two uh we don't really have
money problem actually it's all good
um we can just continue operation until
the end but the problem or challenge is
more gonna come for next season where we
want to build some bigger pieces of
infrastructure and the main thing is
going to be the community center which
is the big ruin we have down in the land
and when you convert this in a place
where 50 people can be so we can host
way more people on the land
um but this also requires a lot of
resources because bigger building means
more materials but we also need a big
solar setup to make sure we can sustain
ourselves and offers a fully equipped
kitchen so yeah it just takes a lot of
money to build something like that but
it would really step up our game here on
Project cam let me actually show you a
bit the numbers we currently have of
running this project
so on average we're here with 13 people
we spend about four and a half thousand
Euro a month on running costs so this is
gas car fixes food gasoline soap all the
cost to make sure we can just run the
thing we spend about five euro food per
person per day so breakfast lunch dinner
and some snacks this year we spent 490
your own gas so the bottles for the hot
water but also for cooking so the
problem we have there which I mentioned
before is actually not really a money
problem but more of a we just don't want
to use gas problem and the project with
the highest cost are the ruin renovation
so all the materials for that and video
making so getting all our equipment and
stuff to make sure we can make videos
and in total we spend this season 38 000
Euro fun fact in September we got money
from releasing a video of our van life
so showing all the vehicles we live in
we use that exact same money to fix the
caddy so we use to show our vehicles the
money we got from that we used to pay
fix our vehicles my plan just a funny
coincidence this brings us to the next
point where do we get our income from so
we got income from YouTube you guys
watching videos which is great and this
money is mainly used for the running
costs and we don't really have any big
bills like energy or rent so uh yeah
it's pretty the costs are pretty low
considering the amount of people we have
but basically all the YouTube money for
the running cost but then we also have
development costs so the moment we want
to build something new or initiate
something or experiment then we need
external money
at the moment we got this from patrons
and donations last year we actually also
got a super cool crypto donation uh for
the ruin uh crypto went up and down a
lot but that was basically all of that
money was used to pay for the renovation
of the room which has been great but the
challenge is going to be the community
center because this development is going
to be way way bigger and way more money
needed so we don't really have a
concrete plan for that we have faith
that we would find another weird person
that really supports the projects want
to make sure it can continue and has a
stack of money laying around
but it's a bit dangerous well to wait
for that to happen because it could
easily not happen and especially when
you start planning this becomes more and
more of a challenge so we're not really
sure how to go about that one we'll keep
Faith but maybe we need to do something
else but anyway in the meantime all of
you guys that watch videos is super
useful on the one hand for the cost but
also to make sure uh the project gets
spread show it to your friends your
family it's very valuable also the
people supporting on patreon I think in
the end that's really the powerful thing
behind the project to have a community
of people and supporters around the
world so no need to do more if you can
it's all good just happy for you to be
here this is just so you know where
we're at the current challenges
um we'll see how it's gonna go no idea
either but for now let's have a look at
some questions that you guys send in I'm
gonna do our q a
have you ever thought about putting an
Air Raider in the pond to help clean the
water up aerator
no we never thought about that
how many nationalities are represented
in the camp now I'm Portuguese
U.S Brazil old Queensland Australia I
would say Collision I don't like this
question I'm from the Dutchland I'm
Dutch I'm from England I'm British
um Spanish is the narrator girl single
and will she marry me
do you all have background in outdoor
Hands-On kind of life never seen people
yay before diving into Tony bush
well I kind of have a Outdoors
background but not everybody here does
but I kind of feel like we have some
mentality of like being Hands-On and
just getting into it so let's go
tell us what the camp culture is like do
you have any Community rules also how do
you resolve disputes
gun culture is nice
I think main event is pizza night it's
quite we craved that all week I wonder
when it comes it's like
best thing ever
uh we have rules yeah lots of them but I
think they are quite good to organize
ourselves
um disputes
I really don't haven't seen any disputes
so far
but I guess we will resolve things
talking
have there been any injuries on site if
so what happened and how the effective
person is doing not yet I think no we go
to the
uh
to the box in the kitchen with the
plasters
I think Lucas cut his finger last week
he got a plaster
I should be the little finger
what about the chairs did you find a way
for them to stop breaking no we just
spent more time fixing do you guys
suffer from homesickness no not really
no I actually feel very at home here
um no not yet
no I miss my friends it's hard to answer
that because I'm from Brazil and now I'm
living in Madrid
and now I'm passing this time here and
actually I don't know anymore where my
home is so I think the answer is
nope I'm trying to find my home if
you're a property communal or is the
work improving the property communal I'm
not sure I understand the full question
but yes the property is not owned by one
single person but by a group of people
how much land do you have
we have connectors how are the personal
relationships in Camp not really sure if
it relates to couples or friends but
feels like one big family
how was your day hey Dave how was the
day of yours what do you do in general
man I would say it's a bit scattered
mainly here on Project Camp helping out
but also here on different areas and
then also have all the digital world of
the software that we're developing and
being a bit involved in all the other
projects of one Army so I feel a bit all
over the place actually it's project
Camp a kind of way to find the meaning
of life that's a huge question
I don't know what to say
[Laughter]
will there be a possibility to stay at
the site in a year or so so generally
you can come here to help out if you go
to support.project.com however we're now
actually closing this season soon so
then we take a winter break and we would
start again in April and season three
can you describe what the local
ecosystem would look like prior to the
introduction of invasive pieces to the
neighborhood soldiers that we had a lot
of Big Pine trees on the land and some
Oaks also some cork trees but
unfortunately because of the fire they
all burned down
it seems the neighbors are happy to have
you around do you think they understand
your project are they just happy to see
new life in their area I think at the
beginning they were more happy to see
new life in the area they were happy to
talk with us because it was empty before
and slowly they got in to understand the
project as we do the same too do you
plan to cut all mimosa trees not yet not
yet
the Mimosa wood has any odor not really
just sort of wet wood now what would be
an example of a better Forest what our
desired species yeah I'm in a better
Forest would definitely be with way less
mimosas show with way more native trees
as Oaks corks
chestnuts like loads of fruit trees
also water retention spaces as Lakes
swales
um and potentially also animals grazing
the land
yeah lots of improvement well you guys
make use of permaculture or some kind of
food Forest not sure yet probably
have you been planting native trees or
plants yeah we've planted some we're
also saving some Oak and cork from The
Big Field do you produce compost Yes
actually we do
when do you start growing your own food
on the land don't know
I have nothing to say really but I
appreciate your content and wish to help
the YouTube algorithm you don't want to
know how much we appreciate you every
video you write down this
is the girl in yellow shirt related to
Dave I don't wear a reality shirt but my
name is Julie
and it feels like a brother will you
stay in Camp over winter and will the
YouTube channel have seasons and season
break again we will stay part of the
winter and play it come
videos will stop until season 3 begin
let's say around spring videos will be
back
how do you feel about the progress you
made so far
gone very fast
what is your favorite and least favorite
thing about making videos
uh they think I like most is
fun stuff
when people do b-rolls that actually
super funny
and I think I like least
yeah when you start to edit the video
it's like you see the mountain you have
to climb there and it's [ __ ]
what can I say [ __ ] how do you manage
gray water uh I think it goes on the
land we only use
sustainable soap yeah do you guys have
jobs outside of project Camp yes I have
a job related with precious plastic
thank God I'm My Own Boss so I can
balance it out myself it's a lot of
managing from here internet and some
work outside traveling installing
machines starting workshops making some
products yes
[Music]
it workspaces
we are working on it how much is this
project funded by press plastic
uh nothing I mean fresh plastic can
barely sustain itself so
what are you planning to do with the
lake and big Rune the Lakes we kind of
just want to make bigger and better
um just to retain more water and we can
actually use them but probably more of a
seasoned treating kind of excited to get
one that started uh Community Center
currently in planning phase the big Rune
uh probably also going to start it next
year and we're still looking into
construction what we can use what not
but overall it does seem more stable
than the sketchy room
how are the paperwork stuff going
not too bad actually it just takes long
and a lot of Little Steps but so far
it's doable when are you going to start
doing the big Rune we already started it
this year but it was more the paperwork
legalizing it and Next Step will be more
planning seeing what kind of utilities
we need in there so it's already
starting but the actual renovation I
don't know also depends a bit in
municipality approving the plants what
we want to do but if you want to follow
this we have a topic in the research
module where you can see what we're
doing to stay updated
hey so I'm currently editing the video
and realize I forgot to record an outro
but thank you all for sending in the
questions it's nice to see what's in
your mind and we'll continue to run here
the operations and see you in the next
video if you already want to see it make
sure to support on patreon if not we'll
just see you again next week thanks
that's a huge question
I don't know what
yeah
we got one say Miano from Discord sent
one to us which cool but we didn't
install it yet because we wanted to
build a new toilet but realized kind of
okay for now so probably next season we
would build it